Okay.
We should be live here. Hello.
I go back to writing the articles just
for about an hour
before dinner.
Set one thing up on the side here.
I don't figure which of these articles I
should edit.
Probably just do both of the um
I just aim to do everything but the
summary one. That's probably good,
right?
This one was higher. Wally, let's just
do this first.
>> Something like this.
Hello, welcome.
This is going to be
local version. This is just a subtitle.
Uh
Yeah, the name of the game here is I'm
just I'm writing the uh release articles
and I figured I could stream it cuz why
not?
>> Does it help you with not
procrastinating?
It's not so much procrastinating as much
as it helps me to stay
focused.
And also like it's useful for um
I have contributors drop by and ask me
stuff about what they're working on with
Puffer and whatnot as well.
Buffers 40 branch. What Boyd's into? Uh
yeah, 40 should be pretty stable. There
are a couple small setup things that
aren't fully pushed to the docker yet,
but it's like it's pretty good.
Which one was the stupid blog that he
had.
Did you increase breakouts?
Uh there's no way you're running out of
VRAM, dude. It takes like 1 gig.
Are you sure it's If it's giving you
that OOM error,
um
check that you're actually like it's
building correctly. Check you actually
have CUDA support. Cuz I think it'll
give you that OOM error if just like
CUDA fails to initialize. I got to fix
that as well.
And I'll nobody is running out of VRAM
on freaking breakout.
>> I refactor this
little bit.
All right. Um
How we do this?
>> I don't know why this paragraph is so
difficult to write.
>> Right, I was going to add some math to
this.
GPU is too old.
Um
You can try an earlier CUDA.
Think we use anything super modern.
The Docker very well might be too old.
And the Docker's probably going to get
upgraded again, cuz we're probably going
to ship it on 13.
Okay, I'm going to assume that I'm going
to add this in.
Yeah.
Well, you don't need proper tank plasma.
You can like You can grab whatever
kooda.
Especially if you're not using the
torch.
Okay, so all we have to do is add the
little bits of math to this and we are
good.
So, this is 90% done.
This is 90% done.
I probably can do a little bit more work
shopping on this, but I'm happy with
this progress.
I'm happy with this progress. It's good.
All right.
Perfect.
Um
Well,
thank you very much, folks. I got to get
to dinner today, so I got to go get
ready.
Uh probably won't stream in the evening
and tomorrow is my day off. I'm probably
just going to clean up a couple small
things with these drafts.
Later tonight, and I got one thing to do
for a client as well. So, I'm going to
do that.
And then tomorrow I take off and I
should be back on Monday and the next
week is going to just be about cleaning
up everything everything for release.
Uh docs, examples, tests. Got to get the
final experiments in of course.
And then there's going to be some assets
that we got to get prepared as well. So,
uh start the buffer on GitHub if you
want to help me for absolutely
absolutely free.
buffer.ai start the buffer helps me a
ton.
And you